what is human intelligence
how do people move and react to their
surroundings as they do
at berlin's technical university oliver
brock wants to answer those questions
he worked in the u.s for 16 years and
returned to germany in 2009
but he's not studying humans to fathom
our intelligence
he's equipping robots with artificial
intelligence
i can't experiment on humans by changing
them in any way
with robots i can simply upload another
program or screw on another hand and see
what effect it has
that means i have an experimental tool
with which i can study the interaction
between a system and its surroundings
and that's just what people do a person
is a system that interacts with its
surroundings
here humans and robots are supposed to
move toward each other
the robot follows the blue sign
it doesn't have exact instructions it
decides freely how to move
and is expected to learn on its own and
explore its world
what about grasping objects
until now robots had great difficulty in
doing that
the trick the berlin researchers used
was to fill an artificial rubber hand
with air
it no longer needs any sensors on its
fingertips and can still pick up various
objects without damaging them
and it can do even more
with the hand robots can find a way to
take an object out of a drawer
it's a simple solution but definitely an
intelligent one
this hand is capable of doing things
humans do when they grasp objects
humans use surfaces and slide their
fingers along them to pick up objects
and this hand because it's soft and
pliable is especially good at sliding
along those surfaces and using the same
strategies humans use in grasping
the scientists develop mathematical
formulas for the few commands the hand
still needs
what's surprising is that not only do
the formulas cover the movements of the
robotic hand three-dimensionally
they're also helpful in an entirely
different field
medicine
for the first time it's possible to
recognize how pathogenic proteins move
that's important in developing new
medications
brock learned to appreciate the value of
linking different fields of research in
the u.s
i think americans are much more
adventurous and willing to take risks
in contrast
germans like it when things are
structured
where there are rules that determine
everything
and especially in research where you
really need to be able to act freely and
react quickly to ideas
the american environment is ideal
the thing is the thumb has to despite
that brock returned to germany
this year to be fixed electricity he now
wants to implement that freedom in
research and non-hierarchical
organization in germany
a funded alexander von humboldt
professorship has enabled him to do so
it doesn't need to go through
the environment i'm helping to create
with this funding and the support of the
technical university is certainly an
unusually good environment for research
berlin was the right decision for oliver
brock and he has no intention of leaving